studying up on early modern English
taught me how an old letter and a
printing press made us start
mispronouncing a Scottish name in my
search for the true sound of Shakespeare
long hours at the library paid off with
way too many amazing subplots to squeeze
into one video before I tuck them into
my notebook and turn out the lights let
me share one story I really loved about
a different kind of English thanks to a
long linguistic past there are more
varieties of English in the British
Isles and in the rest of the
english-speaking world at the extreme
these actually behave like different
languages we meet one of those extremes
in the far north Scott's not Gaelic not
standard English with a truly Scottish
burr Scots it's the local lowland way of
saying Scottish just as their word
English evolved to Engels Scottish
shortened to Scots and consider your
company carefully before you weigh in on
calling it a lead or a dialect a bit of
a charged issue but either way Scots has
its own separate history the northern
edges of Middle English gained a strong
foothold in the lowland pushing Scottish
Gaelic to the highlands the scoped lead
emerged and evolved into its own
sub-branch of anglich complete with
Scottish dialects and even a literary
form with quirks of its own quirks like
you'll this early English letter was a
form of G used for a few sounds
including the glide Yangyi and the raspy
sound at the end of its own name
yo this letter didn't last down South
Caxton's printing press would print G
and you like this but when Scotland got
its printing press yoke was still alive
in yyyy-you and in the name McKenney
McKenney I see back then printing
involved wooden sticks metal pieces
formed to people to ink and press it was
a whole process these weren't the days
of holding down a key on your phone
until you got a little pop up to choose
the right special character
I was literally metal pieces stored in a
type case so you print with the type you
had on hand and you would keep around
just enough to print that spell the
beginning of the end for you the story
goes that when the presses in Scotland
didn't have the type the middle piece
for Jochen or wooden type cases they
just grabbed the letters ed instead
close enough right especially since
they're handwritten forms look so
similar at the time it's not that
confusing either after all whether you
call this letters ed or is it modern
Scott still doesn't use it much for the
sound but some words became so well
known in print that eventually people
based their pronunciation on that
printed spelling reading as this sound
back into a word that never had it in
the first place this short cut didn't
impact fingon ordre million nor the
earlier spelling of the aisle of yet but
it is how McKenzie turned into McKenzie
this quirk is a great example of how
language varieties can preserve little
bits of history even events as specific
as hauling a printing press into town
and picking letters out of a box all
right and I'll follow up I'll get back
to work on the next full tale the one
you patrons voted for consider becoming
a patron yourself if you want to help me
spend more time making videos I deeply
appreciate it most importantly stick
around and subscribe for lead
[Music]
you